That's Michelangelo's famous Sistine
Chapel Representation.
And there's some cool things about this.
I mean,
you got to wonder this,
this,
this is a side,
and I don't know if it's a credible
aside,
but it's an interesting aside.
So that's,
that's a form of credible.
What the Hell is God doing in this
thing?
No,
I mean,
what is this exactly?
And so there's,
there's been some interesting answers to
that and this is one of them.
So there was a group of scientists about
20 years ago that,
that were remarked on the precise,
uh,
the precise analogy between this
structure and the brain bisected down
the middle.
And of course,
Michael Angelo was one of the first
people who did detailed dissections.
And so they felt that,
that,
that Michelangelo had put God inside the
brain for some reason.
And,
uh,
that seems to me to be associated with
the notion that there's,
you know,
there's a,
there's an analogy or a metaphorical
identity between the notion of whatever
God is and the structures that give rise
to consciousness.
And,
uh,
I think we really underestimate the
degree to which consciousness is,
is both same,
miraculous.
And not understood,
I mean,
you know,
you,
you have what appears to be an entirely
material substrate.
Yep.
Here you are aware and self aware and
able to generate the world merely in
some sense by looking at it.
It really is remarkable in that
consciousness is dependent on,
on something that wells up from deep
within that material substrate that we
don't understand at all.
It's really a,
it's crazily remarkable thing.
You know,
when you hear,
you hear a lot about scientific
reductionism,
but I'll tell you something that's kind
of interesting and it's a tangent to,
you know,
the guy that discovered Dna,
I think it was Watson and Watson and
crick,
but I don't remember who wrote this
book,
but one of them I don't remember which
one,
he believed that DNA was so complicated
that it had to come from space.
He didn't believe it could have possibly
evolved on earth.
And so like a lot of these people who
are used
as exemplars of scientific reductionism
aren't like that at all.
When you actually read what they had to
say,
right?
They,
they were very aware of the limits of
their own knowledge and I mean DNA is
something really quite spectacularly
remarkable.
It's an eternal substance.
It's been around for a very long time.
And the idea that we understand it is a
very stupid idea and I would say that I
would say that the same thing applies to
the brain.
Like we're,
we're,
we're scratching away at the surface of
something we don't understand at all.
And so it's quite interesting.
I think that,
and maybe Michelangelo had enough goal
to do that.
It's certainly possible.
I mean he had enough goal to do
dissections when the,
when the cost of that was death,
you know,
he had this rob corpses essentially to
go and do it.
So he was,
he wasn't,
I would say,
not particularly politically correct.
So.
So that's kind of interesting and there
is another representation of the same
thing and that's a funny one.
I had to throw that in.
I don't know how many of you know this,
but there's,
there's,
there's this joke in the atheistic
atheist community.
I think it might've been started by
Richard Dawkins,
but that might be wrong,
that it was just as reasonable to
believe in the flying spaghetti monster
as it was to believe in God.
And that's the flying spaghetti monster
by the way.
And,
and,
uh,
and so that's,
that's called touched by his noodly
appendage and anyways,
it's fun.
It's not very sophisticated,
but it is funny.
Okay.